[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
die zubereitung von lecker gefüllten
windbeuteln und anschließend mache ich
daraus profit holz
[Musik]
dass ihr keine panik vom brand tag haben
müsst und das der ganz einfach
herzustellen ist das zeige ich euch
jetzt im video
[Musik]
dies sind unsere zutaten butter mehl
leitungswasser salz und eier
in einem topf wird das wasser zusammen
mit dem butter und der prise salz ein
mal aufgekocht
[Musik]
nach dem aufkochen geben wir in einem
schwung das mehl mit hinzu
[Musik]
nachdem rühren bildet sich sofort einen
teigklumpen diesem teigklumpen brennen
wir jetzt in dem topf ab das heißt wir
schieben ihn hin und her und warten bis
der teig sich abgebrannt hat und eine
weiße schicht am topfboden entsteht
[Musik]
nach etwa eineinhalb minuten ist der
teig fertig abgebrannt und man merkt
dass da einfach nichts mehr geht und an
der stelle nehmen wir ihn raus aus den
topf und geben ihnen eine schüssel wo er
etwa fünf minuten ausdampfen kann
euren topf braucht ihr euch keine sorgen
machen schaut mal hier das löst sich
ganz von alleine
jetzt geht es weiter mit dem teig wir
geben jetzt nacheinander die eier mit
hinzu
hierfür gibt es drei möglichkeiten die
erste möglichkeit ist dass ihr das ei
mit eurem holz kochlöffel zum beispiel
unter rühren oder mit einem anderen
kochlöffel und das ist meiner meinung
nach die schwierigste variante denn hier
ist es wenig sehr anstrengend und
zuallererst wird der teig gar nicht fest
und man hat das gefühl dass ich das nie
verbindet und nach einer gewissen zeit
verbindet er sich dann eben doch die
zweite variante ist mit eurem
handrührgerät das gestaltete ich schon
etwas einfacher und da müsst ihr aber
auch am ende nochmal mit eurem
kochlöffel dran und das ganze
zusammenfügen
[Musik]
die dritte variante wäre das ganze mit
der küchenmaschine einzuarbeiten und das
mache ich jetzt mit den letzten zwei
eiern
[Musik]
egal welche variante ihr wild denkt
bitte daran dass die eier nacheinander
eingerührt werden wenn der teig fertig
ist ist er sehr klebrig und das ist auch
genau richtig so und dann gebe ich ihnen
in meinem spritzbeutel mit einer offenen
stelle vorne dran
[Musik]
hier seht ihr noch meinen kleinen tipp
damit der teig auch wirklich ohne blasen
komplett nach vorne geschoben wird und
dann können wir auch schon anfangen
unsere windbeutel auf zu spritzen
ich spritze das ganze hier auf meine
dauer back folie ihr könnt aber auch ein
ganz reguläres backpapier nehmen
[Musik]
vor dem backen werden die windbeutel
noch mit etwas wasser benetzt diesen
schritt dürft ihr nicht auslassen das
ist ganz wichtig und jetzt zeige ich
euch noch eine weitere variante
hier habe ich einfach den teig in meinen
spritzbeutel gefüllt und vorne die
spitze abgeschnitten
[Musik]
und während ihr auch hier wieder etwas
wasser auf die windbeutel gibt könnt ihr
dabei die spitze ein wenig
herunterdrücken damit das endergebnis
auch schöner aussieht
die windbeutel werden im vorgeheizten
backofen bei 200 grad ober und unterhalt
zu 20 minuten gebacken und dann sehen
sie so aus wenn sie fertig sind das sind
die ersten windbeutel die wir gespritzt
haben hier sind die zweiten und dann
habe ich noch ganz kleine windbeutel
gemacht dafür habe ich lediglich ein
tropfen von dem windbeutel teig von dem
brand tag auf mein backblech gegeben
[Musik]
weiter geht's mit der vanille creme
füllungen die boston bremen hierfür
benötigen wir milch eigelb zucker
vanille extrakt oder vanillezucker
speisestärke und etwas salz zuallererst
werden alle zutaten bis auf die milch in
einer schüssel verrührt und hierfür gebe
ich zu allererst eigelb und zucker rein
und verrührt das miteinander
[Musik]
dann gebe ich die prise salz sind so das
hebt noch einmal den süßen geschmack
anschließend den vanille extrakt wie
gesagt an der stelle könnt ihr auch
gerne vanillezucker verwenden und die
speisestärke kommen auch mit hinzu und
dann wird das ganze klümpchen frei
verrührt
weiter geht's auf dem herd hier gebe ich
ihnen mein topf milch und erhitzen sie
[Musik]
die milch spielt allerdings nicht
aufgekocht sondern nur erhitzt bis sich
ganz kleine bläschen bilden und dann
geben wir ein teil der milch in unsere
mischung und verrühren das miteinander
[Musik]
hier müsst ihr wirklich zügig rühren und
auch keine pausen dazwischen machen und
dann immer wieder etwas milch dazugeben
bis schließlich die komplette milch in
der schüssel ist
[Musik]
nachdem dann alles gut miteinander
verrührt ist gebt ihr die masse zurück
in euren topf
hierbei müsst ihr beachten dass ihr das
ganze ständig weiter rührt also fleißig
sein und keine pausen einlegen damit
auch keine klümpchen entstehen sobald
das ganze dann ein mal aufgekocht wurde
ist die creme soweit fertig
[Musik]
die heiße creme gebe ich dann in eine
neue und saubere schüssel und gäbe da
frischhaltefolie direkt auf die kleben
damit sich keine haut bildet
[Musik]
die müssen wir jetzt vollständig
auskühlen lassen und es geht weiter mit
unserer schokoladencreme wir benötigen
milch schlag sahne zucker kakao und mehl
[Musik]
nun werden alle zutaten in einen
kochtopf gegeben und miteinander
verrührt an der stelle bleibt der herd
allerdings noch kalt den schalten wie
erst ein wenn sich alles miteinander
verbunden hat
[Musik]
da der ba cacau sehr stark enthüllt ist
lässt sich das ganze anfangs etwas
schwierig miteinander verbinden und der
kakao ist nur so ganz trocken an der
oberfläche
aber seid fleißig fleiß zahlt sich aus
irgendwann verbindet sich das ganze und
ihr könnt den herd einschalten das ganze
lassen wir dann unter ständigem rühren
einmal aufkochen das ganze dick dann ein
und die schokoladensauce ist fertig und
muss nur noch aus gekühlt werden
[Musik]
für das befüllen der windbeutel geben
wir die kühle boston cream in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer spritztour vorne
dran
[Musik]
ich habe mich hier für eine fülle
entschieden ihr könnt aber auch jede
andere spritzte benutzen
wichtig ist nur dass ihr euch euren weg
in die windbeutel sucht das mache ich
bei den großen windbeutel immer gerne an
der seite
[Musik]
sobald die großen sind wollte dann alle
gefüllt sind und ihm merkt dass sie voll
sind wenn die creme an den seiten
sichtbar ist macht ihr weiter mit den
etwas kleineren windbeuteln
[Musik]
hier gehe ich ganz gerne sofort dass ich
die windbeutel von unten befülle das
heißt ich spritze mit der tülle einmal
von unten die creme hinein
[Musik]
die großen befüllten windbeutel
dekoriere ich jetzt noch mit etwas
geliebten puderzucker und dann sind sie
auch schon fertig
aus den kleinen windbeuteln machen wir
jetzt richtig leckere profitables und
das geht auch ziemlich einfach wir
nehmen uns einfach vier bis fünf kleine
windbeutel geben ihnen eine schöne
bisher schale und geben da reichlich
schokoladensauce drüber
[Musik]
dann gebe ich noch grüne pistazien dazu
das gibt mir richtig richtig schöne
optik und dann sind sie auch schon
fertig
[Musik]
falls ihr die windbeutel bzw die
profitiert auch gerne nachmachen möchtet
dann schaut unter diesem video in die
infobox da stehen die genauen
mengenangaben
ich bin wieder sehr gespannt auf eure
hübschen fotos schickt sie mir gerne wie
immer über instagram oder postet sie
dort mit dem hashtag ekis kitchen
[Musik]
falls euch das video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich sehr über euer
kostenloses abo und wenn ihr dann beim
nächsten mal auch wieder dabei sein
[Musik]